FELIPE HOFFA: Hello, everyone.
I am Felipe Hoffa, Google
Cloud Developer Advocate,
and today, I'm in
Johannesburg, South Africa,
to meet the CTO of
Nomanini, Dale Humby.
This company enables
micro-transactions
in various countries
around Africa.
With these devices, they create.
Dale is going to tell us
more about their story
and why they chose to build
their backbone with Google
Cloud.
Also, we'll show you how you
can use open data and BigQuery
to visualize the state of
the mobile networks that
connect the world.
So join me.
It's my first time
in South Africa.
And I think there's so much
we can learn about Africa just
by looking at what you're doing.
Not only South
Africa, but Africa.
DALE HUMBY: That's correct.
So what Nomanini does is we
build point-of-sale systems
to help remote
villagers get access
to prepaid airtime, prepaid
electricity, and basic banking
services like being able to
withdraw or deposit cash.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
And Nomanini got into this
business just to help people?
DALE HUMBY: Yes.
Back in 2011 when we
started the company,
we focused a lot
more on air time.
We wanted to get scratchcards
out into rural villages,
but it's very
difficult and expensive
to send boxes of
scratchcards, which are worth
money, into far-flung villages
and then collect cash and bring
it back to the cities to
pay for that air time.
If you wirelessly deliver
air time, these vouchers,
to machines that
are in the village,
it's a lot cheaper and
more cost effective.
So people in the villages
who don't have a lot of money
to start with don't have
to travel far to go and get
the essential services like
air time or electricity,
and now even banking services.
FELIPE HOFFA: So as
the CTO of Nomanini,
you created all of these
devices back in 2011?
DALE HUMBY: Yes.
We started off with a terminal.
It was very simple to use--
no screen, just some buttons
where you press the mobile
network like Vodafone,
and you press the 10 rand
denomination or [INAUDIBLE]
Meti Cash, wherever you
are on the continent.
And it prints out a slip,
and you got a PIN number
that you type into your phone.
FELIPE HOFFA: And then
you started with the cloud
back in 2011.
DALE HUMBY: Yeah.
Before I joined Nomanini,
I had my own company
and we were doing the early
days of internet of things.
And I absolutely fell
in love with App Engine
because I'm more of an
embedded system guy,
so what I knew back then about
setting up high availability
servers was a bit scary.
So App Engine solved my problem.
And then when I joined Nomanini,
I took that knowledge with me
and we built up our
systems backend,
that does all the
transaction processing
and the maintenance
and monitoring of all
these devices, on App Engine.
FELIPE HOFFA: Now, to be
able to pull this off,
you need to have
network connectivity.
DALE HUMBY: Yes, that's correct.
FELIPE HOFFA: How's
that working in Africa?
DALE HUMBY: So
each of our devices
has a SIM card in them that
links up to the network
and of course a REST
API on our system.
But the networks,
while they're there,
they can be a little bit flaky.
So knowing what the
signal strength thing is
is very important for us.
FELIPE HOFFA: How can
I learn more about it?
DALE HUMBY: Well, there's a
project called the OpenCellID
Project.
And people with GPSes
and data monitors--
typically tracking companies--
take their data and
anonymize it and upload it
to this open-source
project called OpenCellID.
And this project then takes
that data and figures out
where all the base stations
are around the world.
FELIPE HOFFA: Can
you show me that?
DALE HUMBY: Absolutely.
FELIPE HOFFA: This
sounds fascinating.
DALE HUMBY: Yeah.
So I've got this page open here.
This is the OpenCellID
page, and you
can see all those base
stations around the world
that they've collected data for.
I've registered on the
API, so if I log in then
I can go to Download and can
download the latest cell tower
data from this link.
And what I did--
I didn't want to download
it onto my laptop
and then re-upload
it into Google Cloud
Storage or BigQuery.
So I spun up an f1-micro,
which is a free instance,
and I used CURL to
download the file which
is about 800 megs or so.
And then from there, I
used gsutil to upload it
from that f1-micro instance
into Google Cloud Storage.
So here you can see
the cell phone towers--
886 megs of gzip data.
FELIPE HOFFA: And if you
want to analyze this--
DALE HUMBY: Yeah.
Well, it's no use just like
sitting in Google Cloud
Storage, so I used BigQuery.
So one of my favorite
tools with BigQuery
for importing or
creating a table
is you can point it straight at
a Google Cloud Storage bucket,
and you can point
it to a gzip file.
You don't even need to worry
about unzipping it first.
I told it it's a CSV format
and I know all the columns.
FELIPE HOFFA: Radio, MCC, net--
DALE HUMBY: Radio, so
it's like GSM or LTE.
MCC-- Mobile Country
Code, so that's
the country that it's in.
The network is like
Vodacom, MTN, whatever.
Area is like the suburb, and
cell is the unique cell ID.
And from there, I imported it,
and so I've got those data here
so you can see all the
columns it imported.
And if I look at
the details, it's
4 gigs, so it went from 880 megs
to 4 gigabytes decompressed.
And it's got just shy of 40
million unique base stations
from around the world.
I can then have a look at,
for instance, this one--
is finding out the latitude
and the longitude and the radio
type.
So having a look at,
basically, where's GSM?
Where is the LTE networks?
How is the world moving
from first gen, second gen,
third gen, fourth gen
cell phone towers?
So running this query,
if I run it again--
FELIPE HOFFA: So you're
grouping here by--
DALE HUMBY: Grouping it by the--
FELIPE HOFFA: --the
latitude and longitude?
DALE HUMBY: --the latitude
and the longitude.
So that's just doing some
rounding with that division
there just so we don't
get too many data points,
and then looking at the
case when it's GSM or LTE.
And then importing
that, or at least
visualizing that,
inside of Data Studio.
So I took those four network
types that they've recorded--
CDMA, which is
primarily, you can see,
used in the US and
some in the east.
The world has moved on to GSM.
So throughout the world,
we've got GSM everywhere.
And you can see,
particularly in Africa,
is huge amount of coverage
with GSM networks there.
Then we move over to third gen,
so this is like your 3G data.
Obviously also widely rolled
out, but less so in Africa,
but there's still quite
a lot of 3G available.
And then we move over to the
fourth-gen networks, so LTE.
Also some in Africa,
mostly in the big cities.
And huge in the east,
so LTE is big there.
Africa's got some
catching up to do.
And that took me about
five minutes to do.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
You downloaded all of this
data, you load it into BigQuery,
and suddenly we're looking
at the whole world--
how antennas are looking.
DALE HUMBY: That's right.
FELIPE HOFFA: Can
we focus on Africa?
What else can you
see about Africa?
DALE HUMBY: Sure.
So what I had a look at was,
given the mobile country
codes--
FELIPE HOFFA: That's the MCC?
DALE HUMBY: That's the MCC--
the mobile country code.
So each country
has a unique code,
like South Africa's is 655.
And we did a join with the
mobile country codes with
country names-- so there's
a database that has all
the country names and
the country codes--
and then doing a count to have
a look at how many antennas,
unique base stations, for
every country in the world.
And taking that, and I wanted to
explore that a little bit more,
so putting in the
ISO code, which
is like ZA for South Africa, or
GB for Great Britain, or Puerto
Rico--
PR.
And then going even
one step further,
joining that with one
of Google's country info
databases that's
available on the internet.
So having a look at population
data versus how many antennas,
and seeing, is there a
correlation between population
size and how much a mobile
network has rolled out.
FELIPE HOFFA: How many
antennas do we have per people?
DALE HUMBY: Exactly, exactly.
And that's this division
here, the number
of antennas per capita.
And this is actually
per 1,000 people,
so like Australia has got 17
antennas for 1,000 people,
right?
So if we once again
go into Data Studio,
we can have a look at what
that looks like across Africa.
And if we plot that
on a log-log scale
of the total antennas
versus the total population,
here you can a look.
See with the big
countries, it correlates
with having lots of
mobile base stations,
and the smaller countries
with less population
have fewer bases, which
sort of makes sense.
So there's this linear trend.
FELIPE HOFFA: But you
still see a big disparity
where some countries
have a lot of antennas.
DALE HUMBY: That's right.
If you look, this
is a log scale.
So have a look at country
like the Seychelles.
It's got very few
people, at 88,000,
but they've got just under
1,000 antennas there.
And other countries
like Chad, which
is right in the middle
of Africa here--
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
the light spot.
DALE HUMBY: The light spot--
they've got quite a high
population but not widely
rolled-out mobile network.
And the countries that have--
South Africa, Nigeria, Egypt--
and you look up at the top here.
There's Nigeria,
Egypt, South Africa.
So for South Africa's
population of just under 50
million people, we've got
the most widely rolled-out
mobile network in Africa.
FELIPE HOFFA: And in which
countries is Nomanini?
DALE HUMBY: Nomanini is
operating a little bit
in South Africa, but mostly
in Mozambique, and Zambia,
and Kenya, and a little
bit in Ghana, as well.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
here you can get
a look of where you are
getting real coverage reported
by people.
DALE HUMBY: That's right.
Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
And then you can take
all of this data--
this is public data.
DALE HUMBY: That's right.
FELIPE HOFFA: And you can
combine it with your own data.
DALE HUMBY: Yeah.
So we have a bunch
of diagnostic data
that's uploaded to our systems.
So if I have a look
at one of ours--
this is a particular
user in Mozambique.
Every minute we're
just uploading
diagnostic information.
Everything from user
interfaces to here
we've got the latitude
and longitude of the GPS,
and importantly, the cell phone
diagnostic information-- signal
strength.
And then we do a
survey of the seven
surrounding base
stations, looking
at what the signal strength
is of the surrounding network
as well.
FELIPE HOFFA: All of these
devices that you have deployed
are reporting to you
what's happening.
DALE HUMBY: That's right.
Right where they are.
So if a client phones up and
says my phone isn't connecting
or my device isn't connecting,
I can't use your system,
then we can do an
investigation and understand,
is it a signal problem or
is there some other problem?
FELIPE HOFFA: And you
are getting this data now
into Kubernetes,
or how are you--
DALE HUMBY: Yeah,
so all the data
is uploaded from the
devices to our service.
Some of it is in App Engine and
some of it is in Kubernetes.
And from there, it's
streamed live into BigQuery.
That's what we use for
some of our analyses.
So if I look at selecting
the data from one
of our clients for
today, we've got
a ton of data that's
been uploaded already.
And I can go and
look specifically
for something like
this GSM environment.
So I go [INAUDIBLE]--
FELIPE HOFFA: That's
the GSM environment.
DALE HUMBY: GSM
environment for one
of our clients in Mozambique.
Now I can have a look
at all of today's data.
And what we've got is
this raw diagnostics
that's been uploaded.
But unless you're a
mobile network engineer,
this doesn't mean a
lot to you, right?
Yeah.
This is in BigQuery.
And then I can use
BiqQuery's just as in JSON.
I can use JSON methods
within BigQuery.
I can split on commas.
I can pull out very specific
pieces of this information,
like this is the country
code and the network code
and the base station IDs, as
well as all the signal strength
for all these base stations.
FELIPE HOFFA: So
what I see, you have
like a big JSON blob of whatever
the devices are sending?
DALE HUMBY: That's right.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
That's good modeling?
DALE HUMBY: Yeah,
so a lot of our data
is JSON, especially for
this particular table
which is just our event log.
It just takes raw data.
There's no ETL or
anything on it.
Just whatever the device
or the engineers who
build these devices
or developers that
make the app just want
to send up, we send up,
and we put it into BigQuery.
And then later on, once
we've got all the data,
we can decide what sort of
questions we want answered.
And because it's in JSON and
BigQuery can operate on JSON so
nicely, we can extract just
the pieces of information
that we want and build
new data tables over that.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
So you can parse all
of that in real time
with whatever you want to focus.
DALE HUMBY: That's right.
Then from there, what I've
done is I've pulled out--
each row here has got seven
diagnostic readings in it.
FELIPE HOFFA: So it's whatever
the modem is telling you.
DALE HUMBY: Yes.
It's telling me all these
signal strengths and the base
stations.
So what I did is I
ran one of the queries
to extract from JSON and got
the time, the device that
uploaded it, the area--
so that's like the suburb, I
guess-- the suburb ID, and then
the cell tower that it's
connected to, as well
as the signal strength.
The closer it is to zero is the
better the signal strength is.
If it's at minus
100, it's pretty bad.
You're not going to be
able to do anything.
FELIPE HOFFA: So the
device knows to what cell
tower it's connected--
DALE HUMBY: That's exactly it.
FELIPE HOFFA: But
it has no idea where
the cell tower is located.
DALE HUMBY: That's right.
So if a client phones
us up and says,
hey, I don't have good signal.
Can you see what the problem is?
It allows us to have
a look at the device
and have a look at the signal
strength that it's receiving,
as well as, then, join that
to the OpenCellID tower.
So given this, I'm
doing a join on the cell
ID between the towers databases
and our devices database,
and being able to join.
And what we get
is, for each cell,
we get the latitude
and longitude
of where that base station
is as well as the maximum,
the minimum, and the
average signal strength
that our clients are
experiencing on that cell
tower.
And from that, we can
put it into a dashboard.
And this is all the
cell towers that we've
connected to in Maputo.
That's the capital
of Mozambique.
FELIPE HOFFA: Is this Redash?
DALE HUMBY: Yes, it is Redash.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, good.
I love Redash.
DALE HUMBY: It's super for doing
this sort of geo-visualization.
So you see largely this
is green, which is good.
It means that the cell towers
have got good signal strength.
FELIPE HOFFA: In the
capital of Mozambique.
DALE HUMBY: In the capital
of Mozambique, yeah.
But this one device that
I showed you earlier--
FELIPE HOFFA: And
these are your devices.
DALE HUMBY: These are
our devices, yeah.
If we look at this guy--
he's in Maputo, but he
is sort of a little bit
to the north of the city.
So we have a look in
Redash here, and the north
of the city where he is--
it's a bit of yellow and red.
So we can explore down
and see that there
is a cell phone tower that
has not got a great signal
strength.
And because we've
got the cell tower,
we can then phone up
the mobile network
and say that, in
this particular area,
this base station has
got very poor signal
strength for our users.
Could they fix it?
FELIPE HOFFA: Wow.
So you can use your own
data to tell the networks
where they have problems?
DALE HUMBY: Yes, because they're
not going to report it to you.
But if we can give
them data, then they
have fixed stuff before.
FELIPE HOFFA: Well, I would love
to learn more about how you're
managing micropayments
all over Africa,
but let's save that
for another episode.
DALE HUMBY: Absolutely.
FELIPE HOFFA: Excellent.
Thank you, everyone,
for joining us.
Thank you, Dale.
DALE HUMBY: Thank
you for having me.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
everyone, stay curious.
I'll see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]